Speaker 1: But let's not forget the big
one right now. The big avenue in the
culture wars for Republicans is, of course,
critical race theory, critical race theory,
which most of them can't even define. They have
no idea what it actually means, but they hate it,
and they're doing everything possible to
make sure this is not taught in schools.
Even though it's already not taught in schools,
and Florida's Republican governor, Ron DeSantis,
became the latest Republican last week to take
aim at this imaginary foe to conservatism by
signing a bill called the Stop WOAK Act, and the
Stop WOAK Act prevents schools here in the state
of Florida from teaching critical race theory,
even though it wasn't a thing that was taught
you can't even hint at in schools now because of
this legislation that there was ever any kind of
racism in the United States justice system, which
means, I guess, no more talking about slavery,
no more. We're talking about Jim Crow, no
more talking about lots of portions of the
United States Constitution. So I don't know what
kids are going to be learning in history classes
here in Florida because it's sure as hell
isn't going to be American history anymore.
Because DeSantis has made it to where if
you find out that your child is being taught
critical race theory in public schools here in the
state of Florida, you can sue the school district.
That's what he's doing, you the parent, can now
sue that school district. Which gets funding from
this date, which DeSantis runs, so I I guess in
a way, you're suing Ron DeSantis if your child
learns about American history. Yeah. He didn't
really think it through because that's not what
Ron DeSantis does. He doesn't sit there and think
things through. Ron DeSantis is only thinking
about one thing, and that's when is he going to
be able to run for president of the United States?
This is just the latest in legislation
signed by Florida's Republican governor,
Ron DeSantis this year about culture war
issues. That's all the man knows how to do.
This state is absolutely dying from COVID, and
most of them are Republicans. 62000. I think
we're up to deaths in the state of Florida from
COVID, with Omicron out their numbers right back
going up again, just like they are all over the
country. And Ron DeSantis, his biggest concern is
critical race theory that's already not
being taught something he doesn't even
define in the legislation. So of course,
it's going to open the door for any right
wing parent to sue a school district if their
kid comes home and says, Hey, we learned about
Martin Luther King today, hey, we learned about
slavery today. Parents can say, Wonderful,
I'm going to go call my lawyer and we're going
to put an end to this. Now, it's unlikely that
the legislation, obviously is going to hold up in
an actual court. But by the time we get to that,
we will have seen countless lawsuits here in the
state of Florida filed against public schools.
We're going to drain them of resources, which
they likely will not be able to get back.
And that's going to put the burden back
on the state when these school districts,
even if they win the lawsuits, right, they're
still going to have to pay all the legal fees.
Lawyers ain't cheap, folks. And we're putting
it on our already underfunded school districts.
So even if they win, they're going to pay tens
of thousands of dollars to defend themselves
in court. Where are we going to make up that
money again? Either they're going to have to
raise taxes on Florida residents, which we know
Republicans who control the state refused to do.
Maybe they'll do it because it's own regular
constituents and of course not corporations of
the wealthy elite, or we're just going to have
to eat the costs and sacrifice elsewhere in the
schools. There's no good outcome for this, is what
I'm getting at here for the state of Florida and
our public school system. Either we end up with
even worse underfunded schools here in the state
or we end up with an entire generation of children
that is completely ignorant about the real history
of the United States. Neither one of those
outcomes are good. They're both very, very bad.
But that's what Ron DeSantis is
doing because he is now the king
of the Republican culture wars. He's the general
on the ground fighting these wars for them. And
he's attacking things that don't exist, and like
I said, this is not the first one he's done this
year. He also signed the transgender athlete ban.
Oh, no, no transgender women can't play women's
sports here in the state of Florida. Transgender
men, however, can still play men's sports.
Neither of those things are an issue, though
neither of those things have caused problems. We
have a lot of college football here in the state
of Florida. We have a lot of pro football here in
the state of Florida. Three major NFL teams, three
major college teams and a lot of secondary college
teams as well. And that's just football alone.
And not once has there ever been any kind of
uproar over a transgender man or transgender woman
attempting to play these sports and having some
kind of unfair advantage. But Ron DeSantis knew
that he could get his Republican base riled up
about it. And, of course, distract from the fact
that people are dying in this state left and right
from COVID. So it's a two prong victory for
him, really. He gets to pander to the worst
people in the state and he gets to distract from
his horrendous handling of the COVID 19 pandemic.
And again, he's doing a darn good job of
it. Nobody is fighting the culture wars
as hard as Ron DeSantis and of course, what's
on the horizon for us? An abortion ban modeled
after the one in the state of Texas, too.
I am Farron Cousins. Find me on Twitter,
Instagram, Facebook at fair and balanced. We'll
be right back with more on the David Pakman show.